republican brian kemp has declared
victory
says he will begin his transition to the
governor's office today
but don't forget his opponent stacey
abrams she's not conceding yet
desantis has declared victory gillum has
conceded
but he has tweeted saying that he wants
every
vote to count bill nelson has brought in
a high-powered democratic lawyer from
washington d.c
to oversee this recount well
in close or particularly contentious
races democrats more so than republicans
seem to have a problem conceding defeat
now it can't be that the other guy won
fair and square it has to be
that either the election system broke
down or some mystery votes are hiding
somewhere or the entire process must be
tainted
well then there's the other way to
explain a tough loss
well the voters must be racist donald
trump's
instincts were validated in big sections
of the country
the incitement strategy the racial
demagoguery
it worked trump's republican party
is getting increasingly older
increasingly whiter
increasingly rural the other thing that
could be happening in florida is the old
bradley effect
i mean which which once affected uh
lowered the election day vote totals of
black candidates former
l.a mayor tom bradley who kept running
running for governor and
and polls would show that he would win
and somehow on election day
he would lose it's all
admired in race even after democrats
flipped the house
and many minority candidates won from
coast to coast
once the results in the florida's
governor's governor's racing in georgia
rolled in
adam sewer of the atlantic published
this piece
it was titled america's problem isn't
tribalism
it's racism in writing if republicans
ran on their policy agenda alone
they would be at a disadvantage so
they've turned to a destructive politics
of white identity
one that seeks a path to power by
deliberately dividing the country along
racial and sectarian lines they portray
the nation
as the birthright of white heterosexual
christians yeah adam that's what
those policies that led to record
unemployment for african americans and
latinos are all about
stoking racial and sectarian ethnic
fears
it's absurd the most despicable use of
race in the midterms
came from the trump haters and some
democrats
now i'm not calling mr desantis a racist
i'm simply saying the racists believe
he's a racist
in the category of the people who think
he's racist he has said so many racists
when you don't want to talk policies he
is a racist pig
making overtly bigoted
racist statements attacking brown people
attacking black people
when a bizarre and suspicious racist
robo calls were reported in florida
remember republicans including ron
desantis and rick scott
immediately and vociferously denounce
them as they should
back in 2016 the media tried to paint
trump
as the one remember he wasn't going to
be accepting any of the results of the
election
are you saying you're not prepared now
what i'm saying is that i will tell you
at the time i'll keep you in suspense
well hillary responded to that like this
that's horrifying you know every time
donald thinks things are not going in
his direction he claims
whatever it is is rigged against him
that is not the way
our democracy works he is denigrating
he's talking down our democracy
talking down our democracy well the
media echoed hillary
outraged that trump would ever challenge
the legitimacy
of an election one fair and square but
all their faux moral outrage was exposed
when trump actually won in 2016.
suddenly our sacrosanct representative
democracy
it wasn't so sacrosanct after all
mr president i rise today to discuss
legislation i
introduced to eliminate the electoral
college
and ensure that the candidate who wins
the most votes
will be elected president
yeah the heck with the way the framers
set it up let's just dispense with it
since
we lost now republicans even the
president
of course they had their own hang-ups
about legitimacy obama's birth
certificate
which trump himself focused on but
almost
two years into the trump administration
many
of the die hards after all they're
called the resistance
still do not accept the results
i believe in trying to work with people
it's going to be hard it's going to be
very difficult
i don't see this president-elect
as a legitimate president my personal
view is that it was not a legitimate
election
keeping no it's not mine not mine i
think that there
are lots of questions about its
legitimacy and
we don't have a method for contesting
that
uh in our system
no wonder people are losing faith in our
democratic system listen to those people
now according to an axio survey just 51
of americans said they have faith in the
country's democracy
a whopping 37 percent more than a third
say they've lost faith in it my friends
this is really distressing for america's
future
if the people decide the system's rotten
they're really saying the country's
rotten and soon they're going to be
saying
it isn't worth protecting anymore at all
but let's hope that we can turn this
dynamic around there's too much
craziness out there
and this means that both parties need to
do better at focusing on
issues the issues the american people
care about instead of just
perpetual grievance politics it's
getting old
look some recounts are mandated and they
are in florida
and if the margins are close enough
republicans and democrats they should
both ensure that any recount
is done fairly no creating ballots were
nonexistent
now but i got to say it was hardly
reassuring to learn today
that in florida's most populous county
broward
the elections chief there is a democrat
named brenda snipes
now brenda was found guilty of
violating state and federal law for
destroying ballots
in the 2016 congressional race when
those ballots
were at the time subject to a lawsuit
and breaking within the last couple of
hours we had
a lawsuit filed by governor rick scott
against broward and palm beach counties
rightfully he's going
on the offensive against against this
entire
shoddy practice republican lawyers
you better make sure that democrats do
not start torching
absentee ballots in dumpsters in boca or
finding other ballots
other places let's all just remember
that while losing
is never fun and we remember our losses
believe me
we remember 92 we remembered 96 remember
during bush midterms uh 2008 2012 it's
never fun
but i'll tell you losing our democratic
process
would be catastrophic and that's the
angle